-Jimmy Fallon.
-That's a stud right there.
-Morris Chestnut,
welcome to the show, bud.
-Thank you, man. Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-I want to get into "Best Man,"
but before we even get into
that, I want to talk about this.
You were the 1998 winner
of the Madden Bowl.
-Yes, I was. I was.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
-We gave out
a Nintendo Switch earlier,
so I want to talk
to you about gaming.
How did you win this?
I know what this thing is.
Do you want to tell everyone
what this is?
-So, the Madden Bowl
was every Super Bowl.
"John Madden Football"
was a video game.
So every year at the Super Bowl,
they would have
this huge tournament where
actors, celebrities,
players would play in
a tournament to see who is
the Super Bowl champion,
or the Madden Bowl champion.
-I remember this.
-Yes.
-And you won it?
-And I won it, yes, yes.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
I was very proud of that moment.
-You should be proud of that.
-That was my highest honor.
-Oh, please.
But how did you --
Did you game all the time?
-Oh, yeah, oh, no.
So I have a group of friends,
and we used to play
all the time.
It was something that we really
took seriously.
It wasn't just
a video game to us.
It was like --
It was like chess.
It was an elevated chess match,
and we really took it seriously.
-I got into this a little bit
and did a little research.
You went out to -- You used to
go to Vegas and do tournaments?
-Yeah, so, yeah.
It was funny too.
So, yes.
I was a grown man
playing video games
and going to tournaments, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Here's the funny thing, because
one year it was in Miami.
And so I went to this tournament
in Miami.
It was a room full of people.
I think it was like 200 players
or whatever.
And Tyrese was staying
in the same hotel.
And so he heard that I was
there, so he came down.
And he saw me,
and he's like, "Yo."
He just saw me in the room.
He said, "Yo, Morris, what's up?
What's good?
You here doing a movie?
What are you doing? Some press?"
I said, "No."
I said, "I'm in the tournament.
I'm in this Madden tournament."
And he looked at me
kind of confused.
He's like, "You came from L.A.
to Miami to play a video game?"
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. That's exactly right.
-And I was like, "Yeah, yeah."
So that's what it was.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-He was like, "Oh, okay."
But, yeah, it was funny.
-Well, actually,
we have video of you.
-Oh, you do?
-Of winning, you winning
the 1998 Madden Bowl.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Take a look at this.
-We are here with the champion
of the Madden Bowl '98,
Mr. Morris --
-Chestnut, that's right.
Morris Chestnut.
-Oh, touchdown!
-I got a few guys I play with
back home.
We call ourselves
the Federation.
Federation, Yeah!
-I lost though.
But you know what?
I lost to one of the best people
in here though.
-Who'd you lose to?
-Morris Chestnut.
-There you go. Come on.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
Coolio.
-Late, great Coolio.
Late, great Coolio.
-Love Coolio.
-Yeah, no, that was great.
That was a good time, man.
It was hype. It was hype.
-Look at how hyped up
you were there.
You were like, "Yeah, what's up,
Federation?!"
-Because people don't
understand.
They didn't understand the level
of the intensity of this.
This is bragging rights.
I mean, we literally --
you know, we would bet
thousands of dollars on games.
We'd say cash on the console.
So it was really --
it was really a big thing.
-And you had a name
for your group?
-Yeah, so our group was called
the Federation.
And I don't really remember how
we got that name,
but we all had little nicknames
inside the Federation.
So whenever we went somewhere,
like, we were playing
against another group of
whatever their name was.
-You'd just yell "Federation."
-Federation, yeah.
-I was like,
"Why's he yelling 'Federation'?"
-One year we went up north
and we played against
a headbusters crew.
So it was just a whole bunch of
crew type -- crew versus crew.
It was some real, like --
it was real edgy,
gang-type stuff,
you know what I mean?
-[ Laughter ]
-No, no. It was not that.
No, it wasn't.
-No, it wasn't that.
-That is an honor for you,
obviously, of course.
But you're on the Walk of Fame,
the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
That is a real --
-Yes, oh, yes.
-Look at that.
-Oh, thank you. Yes.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Thank you.
-And you wanted this March 23rd.
-Yes, yes.
-You actually said, "Hey, can
I -- I'm honored to get this.
Can I move it to March 23rd?"
Because it was
a very specific date for you.
-It was a specific date.
So, one day my mother just came
and she said, "Hey, you
should -- you know,
you need to be on the Hall of
Fame -- the Walk of Fame."
I was like, "Ah, I don't really
think about that.
I'm just trying to go from job
to job and keep moving."
She goes,
"No, I want you to get your star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame."
So she called my publicist
and activated my publicist
and my wife and they went out
and they got it done.
So, I said, you know,
as a tribute to her,
I want it to be given to me
on her birthday.
So I selected March 23rd
is when I got my --
[ Applause ]
-And Mom is there.
-And that's Mom. That's her.
-Mom was right there.
There's Mom. Come on.
-It was done on her birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How cute is that?
-Yeah, done on her birthday.
-What would we be
without our moms?
-Oh, without a doubt.
-No, nothing.
-Nothing.
-I want to talk about "The Best
Man: The Final Chapters."
Where is your character now?
Where do we find him?
-So, we last left my character,
his wife passed away
in the movie.
So now, when this version
opens up,
he's kind of really
trying to find himself.
And he's trying to find himself
by trying to take away the pain.
And in all seriousness,
he's really just trying to
not feel the pain
of losing his wife.
So he's kind of going around
doing a few things.
-It's dramatic, but it's also
very funny as well.
-It's fun, yes, and funny, yes.
-Yeah. Well, you also know
the cast for years.
-Oh, yeah. Oh, no, yeah, we've
been working together --
I mean, the original
we did in 1999.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, yeah.
I was 10 years old back then.
So, if you guys are
doing the math...
-Yeah, but you were
Madden Bowl champ.
So, hello! Come on.
-But I was Madden Bowl champion.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Federation!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Morris Chestnut in "The
Best Man: The Final Chapters."
Take a look at this.
-We would have celebrated
our 20th.
You know, it's the -- it's the
"what ifs" that always haunt me.
What if you were still here?
What would you have done?
I know you would have
loved our son.
[ Sighs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It gets a little emotional.
-Come on, buddy.
Gets a little emotional.
-It's a pleasure.
-Thank you for having me, man.
I appreciate it.
-Morris Chestnut, everybody.
"The Best Man:
The Final Chapters"
begins streaming on Peacock
December 22nd.